Schmitt:
THE APOLLO 17 MISSION
WAS TARGETED TO EXPLORE
THE VALLEY OF TAURUS-LITTROW.
WE HAD ADDITIONAL DAYS
IN LUNAR ORBIT
FOR RECONNAISSANCE AND
OBSERVATIONS OF LUNAR FEATURES.
THERE WERE SPECIFIC TARGETS,
BUT THEY WERE
GEOLOGICAL TARGETS.
♪♪
Narrator:
THE CREW'S FIRST DUTY
IS TO OFFLOAD EQUIPMENT
FROM THE LUNAR MODULE.
THIS INCLUDES THE 460-POUND
LUNAR ROVING VEHICLE, OR LRV.
DEVELOPED
AT A COST OF $38 MILLION
TO OPERATE IN THE LOW-GRAVITY
VACUUM OF THE MOON,
THE LRV ENABLES
THE TWO ASTRONAUTS
TO TRAVEL ACROSS ITS SURFACE
AT A MAXIMUM SPEED
OF 8 MILES PER HOUR.
OBVIOUSLY, WE WERE PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE DRIVING,
MAKING SURE WE DIDN'T DAMAGE
[Chuckling] THE LUNAR ROVER
ON A ROCK OR IN A CRATER
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT --
THAT YOU DIDN'T HIT IT SO HARD
THAT THE FRONT END FELL OFF
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SO HAVING TWO PAIRS OF EYES
LOOKING OUT WAS IMPORTANT,
IN ADDITION TO THE FACT THAT
I WAS TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT I WAS UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THE GEOLOGY WAS
IN THE VALLEY OF TAURUS-LITTROW.
Narrator:
DURING THEIR THREE-DAY MISSION,
THE ROVER HELPED
SCHMITT AND CERNAN COLLECT
OVER 240 POUNDS
OF LUNAR ROCK AND DIRT,
MORE THAN ON
ANY OTHER APOLLO MISSION.
I THINK ALL OF THE ASTRONAUTS
WERE AWARE OF THE VALUE,
SCIENTIFIC VALUE,
OF THE LUNAR SAMPLES.
I CERTAINLY WAS, BEING A VERY --
BEING PROFESSIONALLY INVOLVED
IN THEIR ANALYSIS
AND REMAIN SO TODAY.
WHEN WE CAME TO A SITE THAT
WE HAD PLANNED TO STOP AT,
I WOULD GET OFF THE ROVER FIRST
AND WANDER AROUND
AND DO RECONNAISSANCE,
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT,
"OKAY, WHAT IS IMPORTANT HERE?
WHAT MIGHT NOT BE IMPORTANT?"
AND ADD THAT TO THE TASKS
THAT HAD ALREADY BEEN DECIDED
WOULD BE UNDERTAKEN
AT THAT SITE.
THEN, WE WOULD
GO INTO OUR SAMPLING MODE.
AND ONCE YOU DECIDED
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA BE SAMPLING,
THEN THAT WAS FAIRLY AUTOMATIC,
BECAUSE WE HAD TRAINED TO DO
THESE VARIOUS TASKS
FOR SO LONG AND SO FREQUENTLY.
Narrator:
SCHMITT AND CERNAN'S EXPLORATION
OF THE MOON'S IMPACT CRATERS
USING THE LRV
PROVIDES ASTRONOMERS
WITH VITAL INSIGHTS
INTO THE HISTORY OF OUR PLANET'S
CLOSEST COSMIC NEIGHBOR.
Schmitt: IT TURNS OUT
MOST OF THAT CRATER IN HISTORY
OCCURRED A LONG TIME AGO --
BILLIONS OF YEARS AGO.
AND WITH THAT KNOWLEDGE,
WE REALIZED THAT
THE MOON WAS RECORDING
THE HISTORY OF THE SOLAR SYSTEM.